có càng mối trường anico tế dị bình vức tạp. Nhưc ra đang thăng cường nâng lực cuốc phòng,
nhằm nâng cao khả nâng sân đầy bữang phó.
Pà nhật bản, phó đôi đông New York City Bureau Goka thu lực lượng phòng vệ biển dịch bản cho biết.
Tổ khu chục cho kai đã được chăm vị khả năng phóng tên lợi hàng trình cho mỏa.
Giòn Mỹ sản xuất, giờ kiến thường nghiệm trong nâng an ninh cùng trong nhà sau,
rồi chúng như này cho rằng việc nâng cao góp phần tăng cường nâng lực phòng thu,
và khả năng phản nâng cho cũng khổ liên mình nhạc Mỹ.
Sống sòng về đỏ những bản cũng đệng nâng chính khai kể thậm tư lượng tâm xa,
và bố khi xí xíu đợi đâm ở chỗ ông,
đứa xem xen một thí bệ bài thung người lai gồm sát của Australia,
để hiện đại hoa không quan còn tại Trung đâm,
ở lập xíu bảo quay nè kiếp thuật thuật nợi tắc phát triển hệ thống phòng không,
trong đó có tự cầm nghệ chỉ thuận nhận tạo.
Các chuyên gián nhận định xu ngống,
các căng gí tư phòng và mở giọng hột các quân sự đăng giá tăng,
phản nâng sự dịch chuyển trong cấu chúc ăn ninh tần cầu.
Tuy nhiên, một số ý kiến cạnh báo,
bây giờ đùi mũi trang của tẻ làm giá tăng người cơ bắt đầu,
nếu không đi cầm cơn u lực kiểm soát tăng thằng.